حصان وطار وضع حصان صني محتمل حذر مسؤول
بريطانيون من خلقه للامن القومي وفق صحيفه
تلغراف واوضح ان التهديد المحتمل يتعدى
المكونات الصينيه التي تصنع في ابراج
الهاتف المحمول والتي ادت سابقا لحظر
منتجات هواوي فبريطانيا قليقه من قدره
الصين على التجسس على ملايين البريطانيين
عبر التسريح الرقائق الدقيقه المدمجه في
اجهزتها الالكترونيه
هذه المهمه تتم عبر ما يعرف بانترنت
الاشياء وهي وحدات صغيره لا يتعدى حجمها
خمسه سنتيمترات تستخدم في كل شيء من
الاجهزه المنزليه وثلاثه ذكيه الى
المصابيح والكاميرات الامنيه والسيارات
وانظمه الاسلحه المتقدمه وطبعا غيرها من
المنتجات
تراقب الاستخدام وتنقل البيانات مره اخرى
الى المالك وغالبا الى الشركه المصنعه عب
شبكه 5 جي علما بان ثلاث شركات صينيه
بينها موبايل شاينا تمتلك بالفعل
54% من السوق العالميه في الاجهزه وعليها
كجميع الشركات الصينيه تسليم البيانات
للحكومه الصينيه اذا طلب من ذلك وقد فكت
مشاهدينا الاجهزه الامنيه البريطانيه في
وقت سابق هذا الشهر سيارات وزاريه وعثرت
على جهاز واحد على الاقل مخبا داخل مكون
اخر ما زاد طبعا المخاوف من قدره الصين
على مراقبه تحركات الاهداف الاستخباراتيه
من اشخاص واسلحه وامدادات وبمقدمتها
مبيعات الاسلحه الامريكيه لتايوان
امكانياته التجسس هائله لكن المخاوف
تتعداها الى امكانيه تجديد عملاء عبر
ابتزازهم وكذلك التخريب ومهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه من خلال تعطيل الاجهزه وفقا طبعا
للتحذيرات لبريطاني
[موسيقى]